sentir
[Música]
y
hola a todos bienvenidos al programa de
los observadores de france 24 es posible
que hayan visto esta foto que tanto ha
circulado el 11 de septiembre 300
mujeres afganas participaron en una
manifestación en una universidad de
kabul y también en las calles de la
capital en apoyo al grupo talibán no
está claro qué tan espontáneo fue este
acto pero las imágenes de las mujeres
totalmente cubiertas con velo causaron
una gran reacción
en twitter las mujeres afganas que viven
en el exilio presentaron la campaña no
toquen mi ropa publicando fotos de ellas
mismas usando lo que consideran ser el
verdadero atuendo de su cultura o mira a
rezar una a sara chiíta participó en
esta campaña el mejor caso de cisma
expresión clouds de facebook soy a sara
y este es mi traje tradicional esto es
lo que me representa
afganistán es un país muy diverso con
más de 14 grupos étnicos diferentes
todos ellos tienen sus propios trajes y
vestimentas tradicionales y ninguno de
ellos tiene nada que ver con la forma en
que los talibanes quieren que las
mujeres se vistan
así que esta campaña es para decir que
eso no es lo que nos representa
él no ha visto a ninguno de mis
parientes en afganistán usando esas
prendas negras
siguen resistiendo pero no sé por cuánto
tiempo más porque sabemos muy bien que
los talibanes usarán la violencia para
aplicar sus riesgos
el traje negro que llevan estas mujeres
pro talibán no existía hasta ahora en
afganistán para una de nuestras
observadoras en el lugar quien quiso
permanecer en el anonimato es un invento
aún peor que el chare azul que fue
obligatorio durante el primer régimen
talibán
y si son escasas
se inventaron un nuevo tipo de vestuario
un conjunto con guantes una pieza que
cubre la cara y una blusa enorme que
cubre todo el cuerpo de la cabeza a los
pies
las mujeres no pueden ver lo que ocurre
a su alrededor con el tradicional
saldría vegano al menos podían ver no
pueden respirar normalmente este atuendo
no existe en ningún otro país musulmán
es una versión más extrema del hijab que
se puede ver en algunos países como los
emiratos árabes unidos o pakistán
este tipo de ropa nunca ha existido en
afganistán ni en el pasado ni
recientemente en los últimos 20 años las
mujeres habían ganado muchas libertades
la mayoría de las mujeres afganas solían
llevar un pañuelo en la cabeza con un
abrigo y algunas todavía usaban el chad
y ahora los talibanes dicen que las
mujeres no deben salir desnudas lo que
quieren decir con eso es que tienen que
llevar la cara y las manos cubiertas las
mujeres que se manifestaron contra los
talibanes en la calle se niegan a
obligarse se niegan a hacer lo que los
talibanes quieran me temo que una vez
que los talibanes se hayan afianzado en
el país empezarán a promulgar el mismo
tipo de normas restrictivas que habían
instaurado hasta 2001
como mujer
[Música]
[Aplausos]
este militar acompañado por uno de sus
colegas está azotando a un minero que
había entrado ilegalmente en una mina
para buscar cobalto junto a ellos hay
varios hombres grabando son los
directivos de la empresa china con mus
que explota la concesión minera en la
provincia congoleña de lo alaba la gran
mayoría de las minas de cobalto son
explotadas por empresas extranjeras los
casos de violencia contra los mineros
artesanales son habituales así lo
confirma richard ilunga de la ong afro
watch de creciera ya no ante plan
distinta de concesión vinieron los
mineros artesanales entran
clandestinamente en las concesiones
mineras privadas principalmente a causa
de la pobreza las comunidades pobres son
testigos de cómo sus recursos son
explotados por inversores que obtienen
enormes ganancias pero ellos no tienen
trabajo los artesanos fueron los que
empezaron a explotar los minerales pero
a medida que llegan los inversores
privados el gobierno cede las mismas
concesiones donde trabajan los mineros
artesanales ante las amenazas las
empresas mineras le pidieron al estado
que encontrara una solución para
asegurar sus inversiones así es como los
militares llegaron a estar presentes en
la mayoría de las concesiones y con su
presencia se registran muchas
violaciones de los derechos humanos por
ejemplo arrestos arbitrarios y
detenciones ilegales el suboficial mayor
y el cabo que se ven en este vídeo
fueron condenados a 2 años y 18 meses de
prisión respectivamente para evitar
tensiones entre los mineros y las
empresas mineras diferentes ongs
promueven que sean establecidas zonas de
minería artesanal pero para los
empleados congoleños que trabajan en
esta concesión la situación tampoco es
fácil los movimientos sociales de yuxian
regularmente el desprecio de los
empleadores
el 3 de junio por ejemplo estalló una
pelea en una planta de procesamiento de
cobalto de la empresa minera china de fm
los congoleños que trabajan en empresas
chinas lo hacen en muy malas condiciones
trabajan sin equipo de protección en
entornos muy tóxicos están expuestos a
todo tipo de riesgos
éstos congoleños trabajan más horas de
las que deberían y además de todo eso
son insultados y torturados
la ley del congo establece que la
subcontratación está reservada
exclusivamente a los nacionales
congoleños
pero hay chinos que trabajan en la
subcontratación y se ganan el dinero que
debería ser para los congoleños nos
pusimos en contacto con la empresa de fm
así como con el ministro de la provincia
de loja la bajamar y sin sangha ninguno
de ellos quiso responder a nuestras
preguntas
nos mantenemos en contacto con nuestros
observadores si ustedes quieren
comunicarse con nuestra redacción todos
nuestros contactos aparecen en pantalla
hasta la próxima emisión de los
observadores de france 24 hasta entonces